I come to this video smile 64 okay let's
see what I can do here yeah 92 yeah this
is a somewhat rare line against the
Kings in you but not a bad one um can we
go for a bank or start setup he was
preventing it so probably we are
switching to a 20 um yeah to a modern
benoni type of position h5 maybe for
each form yeah I never really sure I'm
never really sure when this is any good
door just out of place even with the
white side I have a hard time to
understand those positions okay I hope
I'm doing okay in this game the game
before that was a warm-up game where I
lost it an unspeakably idiotic game on
my part so I hope things will be way
better him so what is he doing trying to
exchange the bishop and don't want that
so let's put it back there um maybe I
can initiate a queen trade I'll get this
idea into the position that same Queen
trade is quite often not a bad bad thing
in the Benoni folder for the side with
the Benoni setup I mean can I do this
all night c4 maybe
be nice to get some peace trades in so
if I go nite see form takes takes look a
for queen bee three it's a little bit
like a little bit living on the edge
with the Queen mmm Jeff but otherwise
this doesn't make much sense what I did
if my queen gets trapped ok might happen
it might happen ok we're OK for I have
bishops III so I know then Quincy three
Quincy three made under seven okay but
rook a for i also have queen bee three I
don't think we can trap my queen
this all looks a bit fishy I have to
admit that ah but Hugh carelessness
doesn't look too or threatening Bishop
d7 Bishop f4 was also quite quite
interesting IDM Bishop d7 was putting
yeah keeping a 4 under control oops
never I didn't see that one coming I
don't tell me I'm really giving up the
Queen now it could be right to be three
look III Quincy form
that does not look healthy it doesn't
look good at all
this kind of thing can drive you insane
on the white side yeah it looks
completely idiotic legs play and if you
don't find a queen we know the Queen you
really feel feel like stupid yeah maybe
maybe maybe this one maybe there isn't
you don't see it I don't know ok I'm
going here Knight b6 yeah but I don't
know if this is so bad at least it
doesn't look like I'm losing the Queen
immediately I'm pretty sure he had
something I mean it just looked too
fishy to to work oh oh he just he's just
after a repetition here maybe or maybe
he now has seen something better not if
I don't really I don't see any way to
avoid the repetition I mean the only
thing that I see after night a4 is like
Queen sexy for sacrificing the Queen
which looks really a bit like like too
much can I go to be three here it is
possible like Luke a three look III
queen bee five I don't know let that
just gamble here probably overlooking
stuff I really feel like this is a
really bad game from high from my end
Queen B 5
93 Quincy for b3 finally traps the Queen
yeah okay this was my idea to continue
which is really really risky and
probably bad but yeah no risk we never
no risk no fun I don't know if this is a
good way to put that probably I'm not
having fun here but I don't didn't want
to draw it's not a very objective way of
playing I don't really have a movie
actually this looks really bad but I
probably have to play it wow wow EDD
weakens the dark squares like like no
tomorrow Bishop here Queen age 6 this
kind of thing time warning
oh yeah I have to like give up the
exchange yeah like Bishop t48 or
something I can that that was what a
game and this is one of the most
disastrous games in recent memory I put
the knight on d4 yeah I can if he takes
it pawn takes maybe he blunders the rook
have to resort to those kind of things
if I get 926 this is somewhat playable
position ok man maybe I get the pawn
maybe I get the deep on here
nitey a tissy move let's try check I get
the deep horn I'm in halfway decent
shape I can check here take on d1 was
check so he finally blundered something
but there was a terrible game by me and
I'm losing games like that on the white
side tons of times so maybe can win once
like that check check white forfeits on
time yeah that was one of the most
undeserving wins ever yeah I really got
myself into huge trouble with this with
this Queen with this Queen salty them
and Chum night a form is given as a win
already by the comp yeah I mean this is
I'm not I really don't know this kind of
position well from the black side
especially night a foyer that's already
already a huge problem Knight b6 I don't
have I don't have a good way to play
here just terrible but the way you
plated he also has a pretty big edge
93-92 wins but this also wins so let's
see how about the comp is giving you
repeat it and I went then no went here
yeah which is plus something night to
see five
wins oops no this one I will see 5 edits
that's easy to miss am a queen is
trapped again 95 was winning and this is
already necessary to continue what this
is so bad yeah if the computer gives
plus 3 in an equal material position
then you know that something really bad
is it's happening yeah i mean it's it's
all winning four wide double time chaput
here yeah night-night f5 now it's
possible there that's wrong with this
idea check he didn't see that instead he
blundered the house so yeah just a very
undeserving victory where he had tons of
winds and didn't didn't play any of
those okay thanks for watching